[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to channel awesomes
or burr report your source for
everything happening around the world
and pop culture and entertainment news
i'm heather ruse and this is your news
for the week first of all the animated
adams family movie announced almost all
of its cast and it looks awesome first
and foremost Oscar Isaac of Star Wars is
going to be voicing Gomez which i think
is a perfect fit in fact if it were
live-action he would still be a perfect
fit he'd have the look in everything so
I'm really excited for that casting
Morticia is going to be played by
Charlize Theron and Chloe grace Moretz
Wednesday Addams and then Finn will part
of it and stranger things is going to be
playing Pugsley that fiddler is going to
be voicing grandmama which again I don't
know if that's amazing or it's just
gonna be strange but I'm on board for it
let's do it Nick Kroll is going to be
playing Uncle Fester and we still have a
long time to wait until this comes out
it's going to be out on October 11th
2019 and again it'll be an animated
feature but I think so far that's a
pretty solid cast you got some good
names and some a couple of newer faces
though that are really good and hot and
Hollywood right now so I think it's
gonna be good it'll be a fun movie
looking forward to it
also in news this week Jared Leto he's
getting a joker movie
I don't even know what to say guys
whether you are a fan of Jared Leto's
performance or not a fan of it that's
not even the issue for me with this
right now the issue for me with this is
it just seems like DC I don't know what
you're doing with your movies why do we
keep announcing all of these spin-offs
and movies that are now in stuck in
production or stuck in some kind of
limbo there are so many movies right now
that have been announced for the DC
Cinematic Universe
we don't need Jared Leto in another role
playing the Joker he's already playing
the Joker in like three other movies in
production right now there's still that
Joker Harley Quinn movie when is that
coming what's happening with that
there's Suicide Squad - again what's
happening with that no one knows there's
so many of these movies that are just in
production and waving around which we
kind of already knew that
DC cinematically is a little bit of a
mess but for me this is kind of the
tipping point like it's it's a mess
Jared Leto Joker getting his own movie
r.i.p DC Cinematic Universe I don't I'm
so dumbfounded and slightly enraged by
this news it's I just wish that they
would pick one or two movies and just
finish them and finish them well like
let's just make flashpoint a really
great movie let's focus on getting
flashpoint finished resetting some weird
timeline stuff resetting some things
that like maybe you realize was a
misstep let's let's get flashpoint done
reset some stuff and then focus on
making one or two other good movies not
a million of these spin-offs like the
birds of prey movie because remember
that's that's happening or the cyborg
movie or that Lobo moving that that's
supposedly happening - just stop
announcing more movies and make a movie
finish a movie and for the love of all
of us DC fans make it good
I'm sorry I had to go on that rant there
also this week we got a ton of trailers
there were so many trailers that are
getting released this week I'm wondering
if it's because a lot of these are
having a winter Christmas release date
and they're trying to get people hyped
up for the holidays maybe but I'm gonna
talk about five of the trailers that we
have going on this week first of all we
got a trailer for How to Train Your
Dragon 3 the hidden world which as they
reminded us in the trailer is the final
How to Train Your Dragon movie it looks
like it's gonna be pretty good toothless
has a love interest there is now
apparently a light fury because
toothless is a dark fury dragon
they are courting each other they are
discovering a whole new hidden world as
the name suggests of the Dragons there's
also a really interesting shot of a
grown up hiccup with a fantastic beard
like looking good there hiccup I'll take
that there's also some new invaders that
are going to be demanding that two slits
be given to them because he's like
poacher and he has killed all the rest
of the night Furies except for toothless
so he wants toothless and they have to
go on this adventure to save him with
the new light fury it looks fun a hotter
tween your dragon movies are generally
good fun well-written movies so I'm
looking forward to that and it's coming
out not until March 1st of 2019 also
another family film that got a trailer
this week was lego movie 2 the second
part which opens on a kind of mad
max-style dystopian future it's been
five years since the events of Taco
Tuesday and it looks like the duplo
invaders have just completely decimated
all of the world and through all this
Emmett
he's still cheery everyone else has
gotten the cyberpunk look going on
except for Emmett he's still in his
regular clothes and singing everything
is awesome it seems like wild style is
trying to get him to accept the world
that everything is not indeed awesome
but there's some new invaders that come
in and kidnap almost everyone except for
Emmet and take them away to what looks
like to be called the sis star system
and the producers in the past have said
that this film is gonna deal a little
bit with some issues in gendering toys
and how certain toys are marketed to
different genders so there's going to be
a bigger role for the humans the real
humans and specifically the human sister
throughout this so I think there could
be some really interesting material for
them to work with the first lego movie
was obviously great and they did a great
job of having message without being too
heavy-handed about it so I just hope
it's not gonna be a little like
heavy-handed with that message of
gendered toys and that's coming out in
February of 2019 and I can't wait to see
what else is coming out with that also
this week we got a trailer for wreck-it
Ralph - it's a new trailer and it's
better than the other one that we had
before one of the things that I just
thought was crazy about this trailer is
there's just so much packed into it in
that how did they get the licenses for
all of those different internet
companies you saw Google there is
Twitter there was Facebook there a
snapchat there was all kinds of
different internet companies and then of
course we can really see how much of the
world's Disney actually owns because
they end up going into the oh my Disney
website and there are different sections
there for the Muppet Show and for Star
Wars and for the Disney brand and for
Pixar and for Marvel so it was a little
almost overwhelming to see all of the
Disney licenses just lined up for you
there to be like oh yeah Disney does own
all of that but it's also cool because
we're getting some stormtroopers in this
and other cross crossa
marketing I guess for all these other
Disney licenses so it did look cool but
most people were excited about the
princesses we saw Penelope get to meet
all of the Disney Prince
and I think the number one takeaway that
we all had from that meeting was
Cinderella smashing her shoe to create a
shake to go at vanilla tea and it was
nice though to see all the Disney
Princesses together I really like how
they kind of took some of the old
princesses and modernize their look a
little bit so that Snow White still
looked like Snow White
but she also had a little bit of the
modern like frozen era look to her so
that she fits in with the rest of them
so I like how they did that I think
it'll be funny to see how they all
interact with each other also this week
we got a trailer for bumblebee and guys
good the trailer actually was not bad it
seems like it might be fun I mean I
don't think I've said that about a
Transformers movie since like I'd maybe
saw some of the shoots for the first
Transformers movie and it obviously it's
gonna have a very similar plot to the
first Transformers movie there's not
much you can do when you have a
transformer who meets a human and they
bond and they have to you know fight
evil if there's not much there's no no
not much you can do with that story but
I do love the look of the yellow beetle
bumblebee it looks like they're gonna
have some good chemistry between the
human and bumblebee they are running
away from some kind of secret government
organization and hey Starscream is there
Excel rune and everyone's fun ever in
everyone's day but it seems like it
might be just a good fun action movie as
long as you know what you're in for it's
obviously not gonna be like some great
cinematic masterpiece but we might
actually be able to have fun in a
Transformers movie @ken guys we might
not walk away shaking our heads and
wondering what's happened here's hoping
here's hoping and that comes on a
December 21st
lastly we got a trailer for a new
trailer for into the spider-verse the
animated spider-man movie and it looks
amazing the style is great I don't think
I can even break down all the little
things that you get to see in the
trailer but I just love that they are
recognizing there are multiple parallel
universes so they straight out address
that the spider-man you're used to is a
different one than this universe and
perhaps the most exciting thing is when
we got spider glide in there so this you
got to go check it out yourself there's
so many little things to see if you're a
spider-man fan and that comes out on
Christmas of 2018
all right guys that's gonna do be it for
me this week let me know in the comments
below which one of these trailers for
these movies are you most excited for
I'm gonna have to go with lego movie I
think it looks good I'm excited about it
you can also let me know on social media
where you can find me at Twitter at
Heather ruse Instagram at a truce or
twitch twitch TV Heather ruse in the
meantime beam me up
[Applause]
you